à la riche les bulldozers sont sorties
prémices du chantier du futur tramway
sur deux rues près de 50 maisons sont en
cours de démolition elles avaient été
rachetées par la métropole puis condamné
il faut maintenant sécuriser les lieux
et préparer le terrain avant la
construction des aménagements de la
ligne B dans deux ans faustineau
les pinces de démolition sont à l'oeuvre
rue de la Mairie à la riche elles
viennent de raser deux maisons première
d'une série de près de 50 bâtiments
rachetés au fil des mois par le Syndicat
des mobilités de Touraine
démolition qui ont deux objectifs le
premier objectif c'est une sécurisation
du patrimoine immobilier du syndicat des
mobilités de Touraine pour éviter tous
les sujets type intrusion squats
dégradation sur du patrimoine existant
et également de préparer le terrain pour
les futurs travaux de la ligne 2 de
tramway une étape de plus donc vers la
construction de cette deuxième ligne de
tramway sur la métropole de Tours une
ligne qui relira Chambray-lès-Tours à la
riche en passant par le centre ville de
Tours comme l'explique Mathis Navarre
qui suit le projet depuis ses débuts rue
de la Mairie c'est à dire que le tramway
rester dans les deux sens donc en
provenance du centre ville de Tours il
viendra comme ceci sur un axe qui aurait
été élargi en cas des travaux de cette
deuxième ligne et poursuivra sa route
donc de l'autre côté en direction du
prieuré de Saint-Côme qui est juste à
côté ou un parking relais sera crée rue
de la Mairie et route de Saint genou la
plupart des bâtiments qui vont devoir
être rasés pour la construction de la
ligne ont déjà été rachetés par la
métropole et muret mais quelques
propriétaires sont encore en négociation
comme Benjamin sauvage on a plus trop
l'impression d'être chez nous quoi le
fait de voir des engins de TP quasiment
au quotidiennement c'est pas toujours
très très simple à vivre et puis même
pour la vie de famille quand vous
rentrez chez vous et qui a plus de
voisins forcément c'est pas c'est pas
sympathique quoi maison grange ou bout
de terrain selon le maire de La Riche
environ 75 propriétaires étaient
concernés au total aujourd'hui à peu
près les trois quarts des propriétaires
ont trouvé un accord ou sont en place de
le l'avoir et pour et pour les autres
nous sommes nous sommes toujours en
cours de négociation à cet instant
l'objectif de la métropole est d'avoir
démoli tous ces bâtiments avant le début
des travaux du tramway prévu courant
si le calendrier est respecté la ligne B
pourrait être mise en service en 208